um Frank said that he thought we would
say exactly the same things but maybe
using a slightly different vocabulary
and I'm really not sure that we're going
to say anything on the same planet let
alone the same universe but I trust him
so I'm now Hancock and I'm the Associate
Director for educational technology
services at UC Berkeley for a little
context both Judy and Ben have
introduced you to some of the work that
we're doing and I want to give you a
little context of where we are in the
institution we are on the academic side
we report into the vice provost for
undergraduate education and we partner
with our technology group on a lot of
the work that we do as well as other
places across campus such as the
registrar and the library but we think
this is a very important place for us to
be in terms of our relationship to our
faculty and our students and staying
very focused on teaching and learning
even though we are instructional
technology so see
so where are we starting this this
session is we're supposed to be to stop
that talking about next steps and
efficiencies and collaboration so first
off where are we starting from UC
Berkeley has about ten thousand hours of
media both video and audio this year
alone we had about ten point six million
downloads and that translates into about
215 courses and about 350 events that
goes back we have Clinton Carter Michael
Pollan there in our events world dan
coleman from american culture blog
claims that UC Berkeley has the most
extensive collection of educational
podcasts out there I don't know if this
is true he says it is and so I believed
him and we get countless fan mail from
all over the world and just to give you
a highlight of some of this in the
different areas that people are telling
us that we're impacting their lives we
have people who are using this to
enhance their current learning we have
people who are using it for lifelong
learning we have this is another example
of lifelong learning but here's perhaps
an idea about how these business models
start to grow out somebody who's
watching the lecture but actually saying
long and go buy your book now because
you're stimulating my thinking and I
like what you're saying here's a
correction somebody who's closer to the
source of what this faculty member was
talking about says I like what you're
saying thank you so much for these
lectures but here's a little correction
for you so this idea of global feedback
and then people who don't have the
opportunity we talk more about them but
i think that there's really a wide range
of people out there who are taking
advantage of this and then there is of
course who is not reflected here the
students at UC Berkeley which is really
the impetus for why we're doing this to
begin with so as we look toward the next
steps
these are some of the questions that we
ask ourselves and we ask you how can we
do more of this better we've had a lot
of feedback from student in several
different reports of late that say their
number one want from us is to have more
media more podcasts and more webcasts
made available so how can we do more of
that how can we how can we make it
better how can we make access easier for
people how can we make sure that they
find us how can we take what we're doing
and help other schools if other schools
want help when we have to discover these
things we have to talk to you guys and
how can we take what you're doing and
use that it leverage that to help what
we're doing how can we make the content
and context more meaningful Judy talked
a little bit about that and then looking
out at all of the innovation that we've
seen today from the institutions and
from the web 20 world as well as our
sort of sister organizations out there
how can we leverage that innovation
within our institution we get pretty
wrapped up in the concept of enterprise
and I think you've heard from us issues
of scalability sustainability and we
take that pretty seriously but we also
take innovation and providing real
meaningful teaching and learning
seriously as well some of the barriers
that we're facing currently I think that
both internally and externally we're
looking at a patchwork quilt solution
right now internally we grew up out of a
research organization we did a great job
scaling that out and OB is responsible
for a lot of that wonderful work but
we're at a point now if we want to do
more we have to make it really scalable
and
and I'll talk more about that later but
also when I look out and I see look at
all of these great tools out there each
one has something that I want each one
overlaps in some way it's a patchwork
quilt how do we make that something
meaningful for our users the costs of
the the vendor solutions are often
unachievable for higher ed proprietary
code we can't integrate how do we get
past that we need a solid foundation so
can we build a foundation and have a
flexible tool set where do we go for
that and the other systems aren't built
to play there's also barriers around
culture and people you know people are
overloaded with information so they
don't want us to make one more problem
for them how do we make it easier they
have technology overhead they don't know
what this is all about why is it open we
have to educate them and we have to help
students and users viewers people who
are learning from our materials make
sense of it which means context how we
provide context in this world and of
course deal with the IP and many of you
have already touched on that today and
yesterday so sticking with our
principles I think staying focused is
really important and we've done a good
job of that at Berkeley and I think that
we've had help from the larger direction
of higher ed in the recent years so we
have to make things scalable we just
know we do so how can we make things
reproducible how can we ensure quality
and reproduce quality how can we ensure
that we can get things into classrooms
all classrooms how can we scale it out
to the campus and in fact how can we
scale it out to hire it how do we make
things that don't just meet our needs i
mean we are driven by our needs but how
do we make it so that you can use it and
how do you make something so that i can
use it and then of course it has to be
sustainable how can i say goodbye to
melon and say goodbye to hewlett and and
let my campus know that we're not going
to walk away when that funding leaves
and say sorry faculty we can't keep that
going so it has to be something it has
to be a system
that we can nerd your feed and be
responsive to and hopefully it's not
just us alone and then this is the most
important thing here it has to be
something that's grow about this has to
be an ecosystem some sort of framework
that we build upon it has to be open we
have to be able to have partners so you
know my call to action is open open open
and you know to me it's got to be open
content as much as possible within
reason open code and open community and
I think that it was Brian who said that
it's not necessarily an either/or it's
not black or white you can't say vendors
can't play in this game you can't say
there's no profit but we have to find
the where are those open gateways where
we can talk to each other across the
board so why open because well let me
stop here let me let me say in full
disclosure that I am also on the Sakai
Foundation Board and I've been on the
board for three years very six months
into the project i joined i'm also the
COPI I on another community source
project called fluid so you can know
where I'm coming from in this so with
open I think that you have to give a lot
it's not free but you get more than a
lot and I think we're starting to see
the fruits of this in some of the
community source efforts and definitely
in the open source efforts like Apache
that have been out there and it are
starting to mature and then this is
probably what the one value statement
I'll make which is that I think open
content deserves open systems it is
going to create some ecosystem that we
can really start to see this content and
become a two way or three way multi way
street rather than something where it
gets continents little silo I think the
archive is here all talked about their
problems around those silos and we need
to break down those silos and then open
community I think open community builds
better processes I think it creates a
better experience and I think it
provides more opportunity as long as we
all live in our little institutions and
are going
sations we can't learn from each other
our developers can't learn from each
other and we we don't have that that
opportunity to scale up what we're doing
and expand our thinking so I'm not going
to spend a lot of time convincing you
about open content I think you know why
why it's a good thing to do I think
thinking about it from the students
perspective from the learners
perspective and then from the faculty
perspective some things just about the
fact that there is a lot of content and
the fact that when things are open we
can find it if we can find it that
engaging with more content and then
especially with the the new community
and collaboration tools by engaging with
more people we're going to we're going
to extend our expense extend our
knowledge even farther and innovate
faster think the challenges there are
we've got a lot of content out there and
knowledge doesn't exist in a vacuum so
how do we provide the right context for
students and for people who are
learner's how do we harvest things
across these different partners and then
how do we really educate and advocate
for this to the highest levels of our
administration's down to our faculty and
students and people who are contributing
their content back and doing students
because students are developing this
content as well often within an
authenticated environment I think we're
going to start seeing that breakout or
in a completely informal environment
like youtube and then how does that come
back in and can that enhance our
teaching and learning open source the
open source benefits that I've seen
across the Sakai community are huge I
think that with your with the people in
house if you're thinking like an
administrator you can leverage the
skills of people across the community
you can help them to mentor your own
staff and then your staff can grow and
by mentoring others you don't have to
reinvent the wheel you learn more by
actually seeing the workings of things
you change your mind sometimes and then
by sharing common frameworks I think we
can actually feel
uncommon applications I think as long as
we're reinventing the frame works every
time where we're going to sit there and
we're never really going to touch people
and really not going to make a
difference so let's get the frame work
out and then work on the applications
working on the things that are really
going to touch people that's why we're
spending so much time working around
this framework building the right
foundation being part of fluid being
part of Sakai so that then we can come
up and we can really impact lives you
can also share support and cost that's a
big issue and there are now successful
business models building around this so
that's that issue of we're breaking down
barriers between the commercial world
and and the world of higher ed so bill
to to open frameworks here's my really
pretty architectural diagram I was a
joke there's no architecture and
volunteer at all this is trying to show
a little bit of somewhat of the creative
chaos that can happen in a community
source but also the opportunity so you
can see over here all of these different
tool sets that are being built into the
Sakai collaboration and learning
environment as we speak those little
Oliveros are showing all those services
those tools talking to each other so as
we start to work on building our re are
detected systems app into that world and
then starting to come down so our
systems app is really in a way for us
right it's the architecture it's what
allows us to systematize and automate a
lot of the work that we're doing and
then maybe if your adopts acai and you
want to do this you can use that a lot
of workflow engines scheduling engines
things like that and then on top of that
we start to come out and touch the
customer a lot more in ways that they
see webcast content management webcast
learning tools and thinking about what
those interactions are instead of
reinventing the wheel around how you
might study with something we already
have a wiki so how do we build in those
interactions inside of that
the students are already in that context
the faculty are already in that context
let's make their lives easier and then
we've got our dotted line and all of
these great things that are going on out
there we've started to you know partner
with Google and with Apple they're
really going to help us along the way in
a lot of ways we touch more people
because of those partnerships now the
question to us is look at all of these
things how can we leverage what they
have done can we don't know we don't
know but that's a big question so the
whole world of interoperability is is on
our mind a lot so in terms of open
community there's more and more of this
in a way you know I went out and I got
all of these different logos really it
is one community you know Sakai service
started long as a community source
qawali came along and learn from what we
were doing fluid is now learning from
what both those organizations are doing
we're seeing more and more overlap
between those and the open courseware
community and OSP obviously is on top of
that so I think that what what we're
really trying to do in this area is say
that when you come together around a
meaningful practice you can make a
meaningful community as long as we're
just out there saying oh yeah you're
doing something cool but I can't really
touch that I'm doing something really
cool but you can't touch what I'm doing
we can't have a meaningful relationship
except to say if this is this is an idea
if we come together around meaningful
practice then we can start to make
impact happen so some of the next steps
you'll see my for my for top bullets
their alignment so this is looking at
alignment across the the organization
the institution that you're in I wanted
to show a quick video of something that
just hit the press so I'm going to
switch to this that
came out from ABC am I switched okay and
just to show what I sort of consider
alignment with the administration making
sure that they're there supporting this
now we started really in a grassroots
way with a baseline of administrative
support and I think we've grown up to a
place where they really get it in fact
to the point that they don't question
what sometimes we come to them and we
say well we want to we want to do
creative commons and we go through all
the law stuff and of course you have to
talk to the attorneys and it's a little
bit of a pain around that it takes a
long time but when we go to the
administration they kind of go oh yeah
okay yeah just just bring that over to
us we'll sign that you know we want to
join those in courseware consortium
there's you know meaning behind this
collaboration oh yeah of course yeah
yeah we'll do that so but it took a
while took a while so I'm gonna play
this record even our bones is the sense
that we are an institution responsible
to the people then getting back to
society is what we're about of course
what you don't get the free internet
lectures is personal interaction with a
professor or college credits for take a
class what you do get is a chance to
learn from experts who are at the top of
it field and I think this is the future
of the world for people to be educated
to know what is true what is it so that
they want to put in their energy on
those things that are important in fur
so that was that was our vice provost
for undergraduate education and then one
of our our faculty who has been doing
this for a while he gets tons of fan
letters and he's quite an evangelist and
we started to target faculty to really
be spokespeople for us and what we find
is that they have incredible passion for
it and as we start to think about
expanding we want to tap them more to
send that message out to more of our
faculty so that they can take advantage
of this so alignment tearing down
institutional boundaries libraries other
parts of the organization so that you
can work in a matrix way you don't have
to read you know do it all yourself we
have a lot under this
but we rely heavily on our partners and
having your partner's believe in your
mission is very important also and then
also the I think playing nice with
others and while embracing a networked
environment is kind of a very important
thing right we don't have to own
everything it doesn't all have to be
this monolithic enterprise so let's
figure out how to be in a networked
environment and there's a lot of
technical ways of working on that or
architectural ways but I think it's also
a good principle so I think ways that we
can really work together is look for
ways of funding the greater good and
some of that is investing from our
institutions at the foundational level
and looking for funders to help us
really start to push things on the
innovation teaching and learning side
helping fund collaboration costs
collaboration is expensive helping
helping us with documentation so we can
share that's always a big cost to
community source and then do some
implementation mentoring how are you
doing this how are we doing this and
actually getting out to the institution
and helping you through that and that's
something that community stores has been
especially good at so all in there